thème la musique et la chanson alain
souchon c'est quand même impressionnant
de voir quatre fa divertissement des
faunes ça coûte tellement cher vous être
tentant à fabriquer des faux noms c'est
pas des fous du monde est fou c'est que
de vraies informations en temps je peux
aller vérifier sur place à face aux
billets d'une maison à laquelle on peut
faire confiance alors france roche alain
souchon est notre invité pour deux
raisons d'abord pour le film de
granier-deferre l'homme au lieu d'argent
avec trintignant trintignant à beyrouth
sound and yellow père voilà et puis pour
votre dernier album que français dans la
main et qui s'intitule c'est comme vous
voulez
alors on commence par quoi alors moi je
crois qu'on pourrait parler de l'album
parce que je trouve qu alain souchon qui
jouait dans le genre un peu frileux un
peu lent guide un peu allo maman bobo
qui était plutôt l'homme qu'on avait
envie de console est plutôt que celui
qui vous disait fais moi peur amorce un
espèce de tournant peut-être même
dangereux parce que d'accord dans votre
disque vous avez la nuit le petit
dormeur s'en allait tout seul dans le
noir pour avoir peur bon là d'accord
vous chanter une chanson semi engagez
vous dites que vous êtes prêts à parler
de cocaïne de ghettos de coucou scan de
mars
le mc du dollar ou de greenpeace qui est
dangereux comme on veut c'est pas très
engagé c'est encore très rambo ça mais
quand même vous avez une chanson on vous
dit je veux du cuir pas du peep-show du
vécu sade et sado ars arc ça me paraît
très dangereux vous trouvez ça va
rejouer bof c'est pas si rose verve il
faut bien s'amuser mais c'est à dire le
ton général de cet album y est il une
nuance est comme tous mes albums ont été
nuancée il se trouve que je crois que
c'est une question de succès les
chansons qui ont une plus de succès
c'est les chansons les plus douces qui
dégage l'image de quelqu'un d'assez dos
mais par exemple sur l'album rame où il
y avait
cette chanson ramq est une chanson douce
et pessimisme est plutôt douce il y
avait une autre chanson qui s'appelait
tu vois pas qu'on s'aime pas qui était
une chanson dure votre pas tellement non
parce que les gens n'aiment pas que l'on
change d'image comme ça c'est pas
changer d'image c'est que les gens m'ont
n'aiment pas qu'on leur dise si ça va
pas dans le monde c'est parce que les
gens tout simplement ne s'aiment pas et
j'en avais fait une autre acceptait le
dégoût qui était une chanson très dur et
j'ai dans ce cet album là y'a une ya une
peut-être une dureté musicale un peu
mais le fond reste quand même
extrêmement pessimiste et mélanger et
cuire
j'essaie de m'amuser quand même c'est
une chanson sur l'image justement parce
que on est toujours schématiser dans les
images moi j'aime bien m'amuser avec ça
j'ai l'image de quelqu'un de doux comme
ça de gentils habille en tweed et est
presque bon chic bon genre alors j'aime
bien chanter je veux du cuir des gros
seins des groupes qu en fait le pari
permanent chez vous en tout cas alain
souchon de depuis que l'on vous que
depuis que le grand public vous connaît
si votre pessimisme est quand même vous
n'êtes pas mais alors vous qui résonne
alors vous c'est ahurissant je m'appelle
pas passer mais je me trouve un réaliste
et vous qui travaillez là où vous
travaillez vous devriez être vous
pessimiste agrément montbronn népal
exprimer mes sentiments tant que
médiateur - oui mais c'est vrai qu'on
doit être pessimistes peuvent être
pessimiste je me semble enfin le monde
et à y est organisée de manière
tellement ahurissante tellement folle
par des gens tellement incompétents mais
je trouve qu'on ne peut être que
pessimiste sur l'avenir des choses c'est
pas pour ça qu'il faut pas rigoler et
moi c'est ce que j'essaie de faire en
faisant le métier de paillettes et de
superficie comme ça je m'amuse je fais
pas c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
fait tant de choses comme si vous
vouliez là pour me soulier mais quand
même dans votre film vous faites
l'assassin une naissance à son fils
ancien le voleur et si jean louis
trintignant vos cours après c'est parce
que vous avez un magot caché quelque
part c'est ce qu'on va voir nous on ne
va pas le voir
totalement à nos voix la première parce
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'actualité
aujourd'hui on est désolé à la barre
je vais aller une autre émission elle à
l'est après midi sur la même chaîne fait
recette avec vous alors c'est vrai dire
c'est encore mieux le rendez-vous est
pris pour ceux qui vous aiment bien ce
qui est notre cas pour rester quand même
pas avec nous encore là tout de suite
vouliez ou pas ce qu'on va parler de la
bourse vous intéresser ceux du monde
beaucoup vu enfin c'est pas vrai viens
on va retrouver christian mary monod à
la bourse avoue christian